selon lyon
[Musique]
c'est l'ère de refaire les co pour
terminer ce grand journal de l'écho avec
jean-noël barrot a débuté dès iv et vi
devant la commission des finances et
secrétaire général du modem bon ça jean
noël merci d'être là et face à vous
olivier babeau qui est président et
fondateur de l'institut sapiens alors
bon soir l'institut sapiens j'ai vu que
vous présentiez comme ça hein sintek
une sintek c'est à dire qu'on destine à
la pression dans les think tanks
fonctionne oui voilà il ya peu décousu
le nombre qu'on est la première et la
dernière c'est parfait maintenant je
suis ce que j'ai vu première et dernière
donc formidable alors il ya une
actualité politique extrêmement forte
mais qui rejoint l'actualité économique
parce que la dégradation économique fait
que on voit que ça va me faire la
politique économique va être un peu
difficile je parle souvent de contrôle
monsieur le vice président de la
commission des finances un mot sur le
casting quand même on aurait proposé
emmanuel macron même s'il a dit qu'il
avait vu il a parlé à personne il leur
est proposé à valérie rabault que vous
connaissez pas ce que l été rapporteur
de la commission des finances c'était
une bonne idée ou pas à votre avis
banalisée a démenti lui avoir proposé
ceci dit ben écoute chirac elysées non
mais les abos était dans l'opposition
mais elle fait partie de cette gauche
avec avec laquelle on a su par moments
travailler et qui à mon avis est très
mal à l'aise avec ce qui est en train de
se passer entre les cadres de rfi et les
cadres du ps puisque c'est quelqu'un qui
est attachée à la question européenne
qui est attachée à l'équilibré des
comptes publics puisque comme vous
l'avez dit elle a été rapporteur général
manager et qui aura bien du mal à se
retrouver dans l'accord qui est en train
de se nouer entre elles et financier sur
un côté pour qui sonne le glas en devant
professionnels là olivier babeau
kassim idéal à chaque fois qu'on
s'intéresse beaucoup trop aux personnes
qui sont quand même pas ultra
intéressant de souvent c'est souvent un
casting avec avec un équilibre
qui est ce qu'il est parce qu il faut
être à la mode mais ce qui est beaucoup
plus intéressant c'est un les
dénominations puisque par exemple on va
innover avec un ministère de l'industrie
un ministère de la dernière séquence
d'ailleurs parce que ça c'est très
important parce que ça va déterminer
beaucoup de choses et la deuxième chose
c'est l'alchimie qui est très subtil
entre est ce que vous prenez un
politique qui peut avoir du poids face à
une administration mon contraire un
expert qui parfois malheureusement a pas
forcément ce projet vise à verser le
milieu entre les deux oui oui elle rend
aussi l e rang
j'imagine que ça ça vous tenterait
d'être ministre c'est effectivement une
alchimie qui est complexe à trouver il
croit que le moment parce qu'on sort
d'élections présidentielles qui ont
révélé un certain nombre de tensions qui
traversent la société française le
contexte économique qui n'est pas très
favorable au contexte géopolitique et
pas qui est particulièrement inquiétant
va lorsqu'il va s'y pencher puisque pour
l'instant il a travaillé président de la
république sa décision d'ici samedi
samedi mais vous savez qu'il a il ay
lafabrie la garder un oeil attentif sur
la question des investitures
législatives viendra ensuite le temps de
l'investiture présidentielle puis le
temps de la composition gouvernementale
si je vous pose la question évidemment
vous ne répondez pas messieurs si vous
avez envie d'être ministre ou pas c'est
juste qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
refusent en fait même je recevais tony
parker donc le champion de la nba type
formidable qu'il vient entrepreneurs
donc son nom circule enfin même il était
en tête de liste et il a dit ici même il
ya dix ans non non moi pas du tout
surtout pas être ministre comprenez ça
olivier chabot moi c'était une de mes
grosses inquiétudes il faudrait il ya
passion général avec une aide à fonction
politique est moins attractif parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle très difficile c'est
énormément de temps c'est pas des
revenus extraordinaires contrairement à
ce que pour pour la responsabilité pour
le travail que ça de demandes et et
finalement vous avez surtout kanigurram
problème est écroué à prendre donc je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui s'en
éloignent ici quand même très dommage
mais ceci dit quand on vous donne
l'occasion de servir votre pays et
notamment dans des périodes un peu
compliqué je crois qu'il faut savoir
c'est gage alors le quiz qui veut pas
dire pour autant que je lisais a
effectivement proposé
leiria beau ce qu'on a pu lire alors
vous démentez
vous savez pas j'ai vu comme ça mais
vraiment et je trouve ça passe pas
exactement c'est que manuel ma croix n'a
eu aucun contact avec
alexis colère il ya différents j'espère
que les noms des ministres sortent si
précisément les les ennemis qu'ils ont
fait de sortir pour être sûr qu'ils
seront jamais ministre parce que c'est
souvent des ballons d'essai qui permet à
tous leurs ennemis d'expliquer en quoi
c'est pas un bon nom alors la lie à une
question importante c'est qu'on voit
bien que du côté de la gauche on attend
il ya un accord entre les filles
pathologie l'hiver il ya un accord entre
possible avec le ps
est ce que on a presque l'impression que
sousse a été banalisé alors que c'est
quand même la fin mais ubs le parti
socialiste et la social démocratie non
jeu olivier babeau est ce qu'avec les
résultats électoraux n'était pas déjà
dans la fin des defacto donc on essaye
de sauver de sauver quelques quelques
meubles dans un incendie qui a déjà eu
lieu dans la zone avant dix ans mais
attendez la ramène pas question 14
second tour mais par contre ce qu'il ya
c'est que entre elf qui est vert on peut
comprendre que l'impôt dû programmatique
y avait quand même pas il y avait quand
même pas un grand grand pas à faire en
revanche avec le ps c'est compliqué
parce que sur l'âge des retraites alors
pas sur le nucléaire ça c'est plutôt sur
leur fait savoir l'europe quand même des
différences qui sont beaucoup plus
grande et les gens sont pas
propriétaires de leurs voix donc le
risque c'est que finalement vous vous y
retrouviez pas électoralement parlant
non plus en tout cas on peut pas juste
additionné les votes de la
présidentielle et il est projeté sur
l'initiative pense que ce serait très
très risqué
cette nouvelle union populaire qui se
constitue c'est un triple reniement
c'est le parti communiste qui se renie
sur le nucléaire
dont le parti le parti communiste a
quasiment est quasi europe ecologie les
verts qui se renient sur l'europe
puisque le programme se le programme
commun c'est plus ou moins le fch exit
et puis le parti socialiste qui
s'apprête à se renier sur la laïcité sur
la question des retraites et tout ça
c'est le symptôme de responsables
politiques de formation politico
complètement perdu leur
bousseau ça fait une drôle de drôles
l'assemblée nationale parce que c'est
aussi là les côtes et descentes droite
aussi voir qu'est ce qui se passe avec
reconquête bon on voit que marine le pen
en tout cas c'est ce que je lisais
jordan bardella dimanche à bfm politique
il prévoit plutôt l'étouffement enfin là
la fin de reconquête c'est une drôle de
nos compositions l'assemblée nationale
encore faut-il que la nouvelle union
populaire puisse convaincre les
électeurs et rien n'est moins sûr quand
on voit le fond de ce projet qui est un
projet de sortie de l'europe de sortie
du nucléaire et donc de régression
écologique est un projet d' atteinte aux
valeurs de la république olivier babeau
risques liés à un risque que il ya un
vrai virage à gauche conduit par le
président vacant c'est très difficile de
prévoir ce que fera le président macron
la stasis vont pas là où on l'attend il
a au premier mandat était très très
constant dans ton justement car
tellement pas là non pas la zik zag mais
une alternance disons
encore une fois l'essuie-glace le en
même temps comme on voudra la plaie ça
m'étonnerait fort qu'il change en
réalité très profondément
en fait c'est son dernier mandat on en
est sûr c'est constitutionnellement en
tout cas sauf
il ya deux options soit il ce sens
extraordinairement libre et il veut
laisser une place dans le pays et à ce
moment là il est trés réformateurs et ça
peut aller dans tous les sens sur les
réformes sociales comme sur des réformes
peut-être dit de droite soit il a le
syndrome un peu chirac et finalement
pour apaiser comme il a un peu annoncé
finalement il se passe pas grand chose
et donc
les années assez rapidement l'avenir
nous le dira c'est assez vite puisque
s'ils se passe rien dans la première
année c'est ce qui se passera rien dans
les cas tu
croyais un risque non je crois qu'il
faut changer un tout petit peu les
grilles de lecture quand on regarde les
résultats du premier quinquennat les
grands gagnants en sont les classes
populaires et classes moyennes c'est
elle qui ont bénéficié le plus de la
baisse du chômage qui est aujourd'hui à
un niveau tel qu'on l'avait pas connu
depuis 15 ans qui coince hôtels qui ont
bénéficié le plus des baisses d'impôts
même si effectivement la hausse du coût
de la vie a effacé une partie de ces
baisses et donc la poursuite de cette
politique économique qui vise le
plein-emploi continuera de bénéficier
aux français les plus modestes aux
territoires les plus fragiles je crois
que l'un des axes des grands axes de ce
deuxième quinquennat ça sera la
transition écologique
puisque il l'a dit il confiera au
premier ministre cette charge est
prémuni ce qui sera épaulé par deux
ministres l'un chargé de la transition
de la planification énergétique et
l'autre de la planification écologique
territoriales pour faire en sorte qu'au
bout de 5 ans la france se hisse au rang
de première puissance
quand même un risque on voit bien il ya
quand même un risque de la bruche tout à
nouveau je crains que les français ne se
ne s'aperçoive dans les six semaines qui
nous séparent du premier tour des
élections législatives qu'au fond cette
nouvelle union populaire repose sur du
sable mais ça me semble très de trouver
les fameuses 100 premiers jours qui vont
être très importants de surtout si vos
siphonner effectivement les lions
populaire farber tel est le nom le une
question sur site la réforme des
retraites alors pas ressortir les
arguments du pont dès qu'on se pense que
ici bfm business le monde le connaît moi
j'ai quand même une question c'est que
on voit bien qu'il faut une réforme des
retraites en même temps 65 ans on voit
bien que c'est pas forcément nécessaire
et le coût politique de cette réforme
emmanuel macron est bien placé pour le
savoir il est très élevé est-ce qu'il
n'est pas trop élevé je commence par
vous olivier après j'en ai le barreau
vous répondre et c'est ça qui est
troublant parce que allait ouvrir un
front sur la réforme des retraites alors
qu'il ya un front très compliqué sur
l'inflation sur le pouvoir d'achat où il
très attendu où la transition écologique
et profondément inflationnistes aussi
donc il va falloir arriver à sa faire
avancer comme ça sans que ça crée des
fractures terrible on a l'impression que
ça va être un front très difficile il ya
eu il y avait eu deux années quasiment
deux tentatives en fait de négociations
il ya vu la négociation n'était arrivé à
rien reparti revenir sur le métier en
ayant finalement quasiment déjà annoncé
que va la solution parmi les trois
possibles soit vous comme le système est
fermé sur la répartition soit vous avez
des pensions ni baisse des cotisations
qui augmente soit vous travailler plus
longtemps donc il ya un moment donné on
a un peu tout ça il ya une seule
solution quant au travailler plus
longtemps et donc on sait qu'il va
falloir y arriver on sait que ça va être
très compliqué les syndicats ont déjà
laissé qu'ils étaient vent debout à
rivery rouvrir ce deuxième front qui
sera le premier front bas qui serait
alors quand en réalité pour moi
l'inflation est plus compliqué ces
problèmes le plus lu pour l'instant
insoluble ça me paraît un peu risqué
ouais je crois qu'il faut engager ce
chantier dès les premiers jours du
quinquennat parce que c est au début
d'un quinquennat qu'on peut mener les
réformes les plus ambitieux la semec
tous les tous les syndicats contre lui
et malheureusement y verriez il les a
tous appelés ils sont tous contre la
réforme des retraites c'est une manière
à la fois de sauver le système de
retraite par répartition mais aussi de
dégager des marges de manoeuvre pour
réussir un certain nombre de défis celui
de la transition écologique et celui de
la préservation de notre modèle social
de la santé ça manque de l'énorme la ja
vrais arguments à l'étranger les
français attendent des services publics
de meilleure qualité pour la santé pour
l'école aimé ça s'appelle une richesse
plus importantes qui ne peut être créé
que si nous travaillons un peu plus
longtemps et par ailleurs le système des
retraites c'est une formidable
protection pour vous il a raison on va
on verra la dégradation économique en
plus vous êtes économiste agen alvaro la
dégradation économique ça va perturber
un peu olive il disait que ce soit
l'inflation même sur le chômage tatoué
pris un peu retournement là d'un succès
ce nouveau quinquennat emmanuel macron a
déjà dit que dès les premières semaines
et peut-être dès les premiers jours du
mois de juillet un certain nombre de
décisions seraient prises s'agissant du
pouvoir d'achat avec
l'arrière d'un des principes liste des
retraites la revalorisation du point
d'indicé le triplement de la prime
macron c'est les entreprises qui l'a qui
la paye et puis ensuite dans l'est dans
les jours qui vont suivre
la prolongation du plan de résidence
assez pour faire face à l'urgence de la
flambée des prix d'accord mais on a les
moyens et 600 milliards de dettes nous
reprendre les c'est l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles nous faut travailler un
petit peu plus longtemps pour pouvoir
dans ces cas là dans les cas de crises
être en mesure d'apporter des réponses
aux français aux entreprises pour sauver
des emplois pas évident votre
démonstration parlons jean-noël barrot
si vous voulez ce qui a permis le quoi
qu'il en coûte c'est en partie le fait
qu'une partie que les finances publiques
avait été assainie pendant les premières
années du quinquennat de la même manière
nous avons là une crise qui pour partie
transitoire et qui appelle des réponses
fortes pour les ménages comme pour les
entreprises mais ça suppose aussi
d'avoir une trajectoire pour les
finances publiques et cette trajectoire
elle passe notamment mais pas seulement
par la réforme des retraites ali et
maman parenthèse dure un problème qui va
se poser vite c'est la revalorisation
des pensions de retraites si on l'a fait
à la hauteur de l'inflation ça ça
déséquilibre est profané le régime parce
que derrière les cotisations qui sont
versées elles sont sur des salaires qui
n'ont pas forcément encore en laqué avec
le smic déjà plus de 65 est exactement
et il est très probable que la gestion
de l'inflation mais nous ramène nous
ramène au problème de la dette était
déséquilibre des comptes publics qui
sera quand même un problème qui n'a pas
réellement été abordé au premier
quinquennat et auquel il va falloir
finir par faire face derrière il ya
évidemment celui de la réforme de l'état
et du système de protection 5 pass
campus mène là on en a parlé il avec la
les taux d'intérêt ils montent donc le
problème de la dette française là on
voit en cela on va se la prendre de
plein fouet bien sûr et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que les français
entendent ans la challenger marine le
pen proposait de réduire le ou en tout
cas de deux d'avancer l'âge de départ à
la retraite ont considéré qu'il y avait
là une forme de folie parce que si nous
voulons maintenir notre système social
sans creuser les déficits et les
transmettre à nos enfants il faut d'une
manière ou d'une autre créer plus de
richesses et ça ça passe par où il
fallait montrer que l'art est dans l'air
est très sain sera pas pour tout de
suite la halle à ses urgences et c'est
une question c'est à court terme
maintenant cela dommage avant tout c'est
la trajectoire qui compte et notre
objectif à nous c'est de ramener le
déficit sous la barre des 3% à l'horizon
2027 il avait déjà eu site c'est le
premier cela qu'elle était fait avant à
bas le déficit allait la france n'avait
jamais présenté un budget sous la barre
des 3% de déficit sous le quinquennat
sarkozy sous le quinquennat ouvrant pour
la première fois avec emmanuel macron en
2018 et en 2019 le déficit était en
dessous des 3% parce que si malgré tout
il ya eu des économies de fête et la
réforme des chambres de commerce mai où
la réforme des aides au logement il ya
eu la suppression des emplois aidés tout
ça on s'en souvient quand on a été sur
les marchés on nous a suffisamment
critiqué ça a conduit à dégager quelques
marges de manoeuvre alibaba mois de la
fin est quand même sur le lait le faut
donner ce premier jour si miss
évidemment situation de l'emploi qui est
quand même assez lente et très bonne
nouvelle est excellente pourvu que ça
dure comme disait laetitia n'est ce pas
et évidemment le point de grande
inquiétude c'est la stagflation c'est à
dire la stagnation activités la
prévision de croissance qui baissent
parce qu'évidemment derrière là encore
c'est des implications en termes de en
termes de dette de trajectoire
budgétaire mais pas du tout les même si
la croissance se tasse réponse quand on
sera encore la réponse à la réponse
avait écouté
oui mais quelques jours riz ou lula
n'est pas de date j'ai pas la date à
vous donner
dans tous les cas samedi 11h investiture
du nouveau président de la république
l'ancien prennent la république est
bonne elle mâcon merci j'en avais marre
d'avoir été avec nous mêmes